ladies and gentlemen the circus
continues
and today i'd like to announce my
official endorsement
for mayor of london take it away
sorry guys sorry that's the wrong clip
that's actually brian rose uh going
after asian hate
what i meant to say is that i'm
endorsing this man
for mayor of london my apologies this
london politics is most respectable this
is count
bin face and he's brian's biggest
competitor right now
it's a narcissist versus a literal
bucket
and i wanted to say that uh i'm for the
bucket
i think it holds more water let's check
it out
[Music]
okay this is definitely gonna get us
copyrighted but you can see
here's a man he wears a trash
bin on his head and i think it's because
he's it's commentary on politics
i i love this man i like what he's about
his policies are incredible i don't know
what his policies are but i'm sure
they're incredible
let's listen to actually one of them
let's go let's go why not two
free parking between vine street and the
strand
you guys heard it free parking between
vine street and the strand
here's a man with real ideas whereas you
have brian
whose biggest idea to stop asian hate is
this
i mean i rest my case i rest it on you
who do you want to win guys it's pretty
clear
that uh sadiq khan i mean look he's
gonna win right
this is just a fact i don't make the
rules but
in uh back here back way back here
over on other candidates there's
obviously this is a guy with one percent
and there's just a bucket of tons of
people so all these guys have left less
than one percent
brian rose is in that bucket so is count
been faced and i
for one am endorsing count been faced
because i want to see
if the coffeezilla army can get a guy
with a bucket on his head
ahead of a man spending millions of
dollars
on his grifting platform millions of
your money by the way
your your your hard earned dollars
because he's using the donations maybe
you got to use the donations not to
mention he's uh
you know going back and shilling crypto
again with tikka tawari that
idiot so yeah i wanted to put this in
and to really get you
motivated to vote for count bin face i'm
not gonna play you count ben faith
i'm gonna play you brian rose is this
the man you wanna see
get second to last place no
right you want to see him get last
[Music]
you can't reach me brian you ain't got
that reach
brian when he sees a coffeezilla video
brian when he figures out you didn't
donate
now look at that face man brian when he
figures out that he's pulling in last
place
oh man now guys some of you are gonna
say stephen this is kind of a pointless
video are you just doing this
to show us random clips of brian being a
jackass
yes oh man i can't get enough of this
guy listen he is the uh
look jay mazzini was the chief clown
officer he's now
in prison brian rose has reofficially i
guess this means that he's got now the
crown
the copy zilla chief clown it's hard to
get it's a coveted prize
sought after by benny but brian brings
the entertainment let me tell you
i i don't know anyone bringing it like
him and uh yeah i'm happy to say that
we the coffeezilla army is officially in
the ring
for mayor of london via via
the count been faced know nothing about
this man
other than he's running for mayor
against brian rose he's just like a
humble guy i think he could barely
afford the ten thousand dollar
you know uh entry ticket to be mayor of
london and he's just the sweet guy
overall he doesn't have millions of
dollars backing him
meanwhile you have brian rose this man
is literally spending
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
yeah he's been
he's been boosting himself because
normally he gets like 2000 views of
video
he's been boosting himself to millions
of views okay i don't know if you can
see that so normally he gets like
2.9 k on some of these he's getting you
know 900 000 views 800 000 views 500 000
views
it's because he's boosting them with
google ads via
the donations boys so you know what to
do you know that brian's real
opponent is not sadiq khan it's count
been faced
and i for one am not gonna let him lose
i will throw
my weight the full dollar bills of the
coffeezilla army behind
count been faced if i have to quite
frankly count
get in touch if you want to do some
press with me i'd be happy to support
you and platform you
we'll be watching the london elections
live whenever they are
i got to figure that out i don't know
anything about london elections and uh
yeah that's basically it
please when you go to the polls remember
what's important okay please i i beg of
you
watch
please
i'll see you guys next time
i know what you need nothing but a trick
trying to tell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee